riots racism and surprise viruses that
kill you in a matter of days no it's not
the year 2020 this is the latest season
of 13 reasons why for those of you who
are familiar with my channel I tend to
do ending explained videos for these
types of shows but as I got further into
this season there were some major
absolutely bonkers events in this show
that simply could not be explained so I
came up with 13 major problems with
season 4 I actually came up with 30 but
these are my top 13 now if you haven't
seen the show or the latest season don't
worry I'll try to provide the proper
context for each of these points so you
can follow along in no particular order
let's get into it
number 1 the adult spying cabal over the
course of the season that kids get the
sneaking suspicion that someone or
something has been spying on them what
if they're watching all of us yeah
that's what I don't get for example
Jessa's father knew about the fonder
drink party and Clay's mom knew he was
at the mall even though he never
mentioned it that's because the parents
have secretly banded together to create
an app that spies on their children we
know many of you have downloaded Dave's
apps to read emails and texts follow
online activity geo track your kids but
if you don't have the apps yet I'll just
talk to Dave never mind how this is
totally illegal let's just think about
the ethics of this do you really want
parents having access to your kids
webcams private emails the potential for
abuse here is staggering not to mention
the complete breach of privacy I mean
God knows what my parents would find if
they had access to my search history and
what about the parents is there not one
parent in an entire school that's
thinking hey I want to protect my kid no
but this is completely unethical so
we're supposed to believe that roughly
hundreds of parents kept this as a
secret
then there's the logistics of creating
an app that can do all these things
usually texts are so deeply encrypted
that even the FBI for example has
struggled to find backdoors to the
iPhone but this app is like the Swiss
Army knife of apps it can somehow
uncover
emails geolocate your kid follow what
they're searching to develop this would
take years and a team of experienced
coders if at all possible
but apparently Dave can do it in a few
weeks thanks Dave
number two the school showed about
halfway through the season these show
tackles one of the most serious issues
facing young kids today school chains I
had to bleep it out or else I'll get
demonetised - Thank You YouTube over the
course of this absolutely harrowing
episode we see the trauma all these kids
go through just calls her mother and
tells her she loves her as bullets can
be heard in the background
Tyler holds up in the girls washroom
thinking he'll be the next one to die
and one of the jocks experiences a
mental breakdown it's terrifying
and then what happens uh it's just a
drill yes the principal decided to stage
a mock drill that involved police
dressed up in army camo bullet blanks to
recreate the actual sounds of gunfire
and he didn't bother to tell any of the
teachers this is so horrendously
unethical I don't even know where to
begin the amount of trauma these kids
went through on this day is enough to
scar them for life it's so bad in fact
that it triggers one of clays
dissociative episodes and he steals one
of the officers guns secondly I find it
unbelievable how this all played out all
the schools entrances have metal
detectors and the guards are all armed
and patrol the halls yet none of the
students mention this no one was like
hey we have like ten armed guards at
this school we'll be fine
now it's been a few years since I've
been to high school but can someone in
the comments answer me if schools have
gotten so bad that kids are actually
taught how to mend bullet wounds
is this a real thing now this is going
to segue into my third point almost none
of the characters face any repercussions
for their actions let's start with
principal Bolin who did this drill faces
no repercussions or backlash from the
parents but there's one character in
particular who gets away with the most
ludicrous things yet is still allowed to
attend school when it's clear he needs
professional help I'm talking of course
about clay so let's take a look at some
of his greatest hits clay
bird in fake blood interrupts the school
dance while holding a knife nothing
happens
clay is found hovering over the body of
a drunk girl at a frat party and tries
to run away when he's discovered nothing
happens
clay steals a gun from a police officer
and holds up the school nothing happens
clay escapes confinement at the psych
hospital nothing happens clay is caught
in the middle of a gun deal clay incites
a riot clay beats the [ __ ] out of the
sheriff's daughter's boyfriend clay
torches the principal's car clay yells
at the principal cue mother clay
vandalizes the school with graffiti clay
smashes the security cameras clay holds
up the Sheriff's Office by telling
everyone he has a gun
basically clay can do no wrong whatever
he does it doesn't matter there's almost
no repercussions so if nothing matters
like why bother my thoughts exactly play
and even Alec's the person who actually
murdered someone gets away with it
number four the riots I thought it was
amazing how 13 reasons why was tackling
the topic of police oppression before
the recent events of George Floyd and
the BLM protests however the way they
went about addressing it is unbelievably
ignorant so in retaliation for the
school and parents basically spying on
the kids and the ever-increasing
presence of the police force the kids
staged a walkout and instead of going
home they kind of just mill about
outside the school so what does the
principal due to these unarmed peaceful
demonstrating kids calls the riot police
not only does he call the riot police
but he actually has them attacked the
kids can you imagine if this ever
happened in real life can you imagine
the army of Carens descending upon the
police headquarters wondering why their
14 year old was clubbed in the head how
much press attention a school using riot
police to beat up its students would get
but don't worry no one faces any real
punishment and they all still get to go
to prom number five
Zac Zac Dempsey was my personal favorite
character this season he's that
stereotypical [ __ ] jock but deep down
he has a heart of gold who will do
anything to protect his friends his
bromance with Alex rout the season was
one of the highlights and how he dealt
with Alex kissing him just goes to show
you how much of a stand-up guy he is but
there was one scene that completely
dismantled everything good about him an
entire sea
of liking this guy was thrown away
because Charlie and Alex catch him
trying to r-word the prostitute he
brought to prom I really have no idea
why this scene was in here and it's
obvious he was gonna do something really
bad since we catch him with his pants
unbuckled and he locked the door so no
one could get in to make matters worse
there are no repercussions for him
either just Charlie chastising him to
quote be better in addition to this his
substance abuse problem is taken to the
extreme where it borders on caricature
there are maybe only two scenes in the
entire season where he's not drinking we
get it he has an alcohol problem but
does he need to have a hidden flask he
takes a swig from in every scene it
almost becomes like a comedic element
then there's the question of his super
healing abilities take a look at this
car crash he gets in at the end of
episode 5 like I'm surprised no one died
here the car totally flips multiple
times over the edge of a cliff and here
is Zack the next day oh and I also
forgot to mention that clay was drunk
driving here and nothing happens to him
or how about when Zack gets brutally
punched in the face a dozen times by
Diego near the end of the season here he
is the next day he should look like an
MMA fighter after a match number 6 aids
oh I guess I'm demonetised now yes the
final episode of the show is a
heart-wrenching look at the effects of
hiv/aids on the character of Justin but
it's almost as though the writers never
consulted with any medical professionals
on how this disease progresses in the
show justin is relatively healthy
throughout the entire season only
developing a small flu near the end and
even having enough strength to attend
prom and dance the night away a week
later he's dead in reality HIV takes
about five to ten years before it
develops into AIDS and once you have
AIDS that process can take an additional
one or two years before one dies we're
supposed to believe Justin's contraction
of the virus and eventually death the
AIDS happened in a matter of months
Justin dying of AIDS this becomes a
cheap a plot device to kill him off if
the writers really wanted to do this
storyline justice they would have
brought him in an episode 1 HIV positive
and we see how this affects him and his
throughout the entire 10 episodes it
would have been way more emotional and
better justice to those who actually
suffer from HIV and AIDS number 7 Tyler
is a police informant
yes what better person to deal with
dangerous gun dealers than a high
schooler throughout the season we found
that Tyler is working with the police as
an informant to bring down illegal gun
dealers first I questioned if this is
even legal
second the ethics behind it are absurd
you want a kid doing these dangerous
operations at the end of episode seven
Tyler even has a gun put to his head not
to mention this episode ends with a big
cliffhanger of this dangerous dealer and
the sound of a gunshot but in the next
episode it's totally brushed off and we
don't know who if anyone got shot and
everyone kind of goes about their
business as if nothing ever happened
number eight anticlimactic ending this
whole season centered around the kids
trying to hide the fact they were all
involved with the death of Bryce from
season three much of the season focused
on Winston trying to uncover who the
real killer was and it becomes this sort
of cat-and-mouse game whether or not
they'll be caught or if one of the kids
will betray the others and go to the
authorities everything seemed to be
building to some sort of climactic
ending but what we get is kind of a dud
considering this was the main driving
force of the season
Winston finds that Alex drowned Bryce
and is okay with it that's it that's
that's the ending even sheriff Diaz has
enough and closes the case even though
the whole season it's hinted that he's
secretly looking into things and trying
to get to the bottom of it number 9 clay
clay sucks sorry I just need to say it
but this season there's just no real
reason to root for him and the writing
makes me not like him at almost every
turn not only does he not learn from
almost any of his mistakes luckily due
to a lack of repercussions as I outlined
above but he spends most of the season
talking about how love doesn't exist and
it just hurts people how he has no
control life sucks
etc he's also a total [ __ ] my mom and
dad they're not your parents who stop
pretending they are and are we totally
going to forget that he left Zach to die
after the car crash a car crash heat
caused by being too drunk these
decisions in my mind make me not want to
for him even though he eventually
patches things up with Zack and Justin
number 10 Estella Estella is a new
character this season who is the sister
of a character named Monty who died in
jail last season after the kids pin
braces murder on him it's too bad she
has absolutely no bearing on the story
whatsoever in fact you could take her
out of the season and it wouldn't change
anything which is a major bummer since
there was so much potential here she
could have been actively working with
the jocks Winston or even Sheriff Diaz
to exonerate her brother who falsely was
accused of murder instead she's just
kind of there with little to no impact
on the main plot number 11 college
interviews with minor exceptions almost
all the characters get into the schools
of their choice even though they have
absolutely disastrous interviews with
their respective colleges
not to mention they've just been
involved in the craziest [ __ ] check out
Justin's interview here I had sex with
men for money or how about Clay's here
what do you like most about robots
making them robots okay I hate to sound
like some old parent here but what
message does that send to kids they can
basically get away with murder
hold the school hostage like their
principal's car on fire but hey it will
have no bearing on whether you get into
college or not number 12
racism for a show that prides itself on
tackling controversial and taboo
subjects the show rarely addresses race
even though much of the cast our POC in
fact in the entire last season it's only
addressed once why students of color
were disproportionately singled out in
the questioning for a season that deals
with an overbearing police presence at
school you'd think they ventured deeper
into how this affects students of color
for example why is Diego arrested after
he fights with Justin but Justin isn't
how come there isn't any backlash or
even commentary on this how come Tony a
person of Hispanic descent is
systematically harassed by one of the
cops who calls him padilha instead of
Padilla my problem here is that the show
is basically screaming to discuss this
but doesn't go and
further than a superficial level and
it's such a shame since you have an
amazing cast of diverse perspectives it
could have sparked several really
interesting character arcs and
motivations number thirteen miner
quibbles and I'm gonna leave you with a
speed round of some of my minor problems
like why is the anti sexual assault
group called ho why does on the
unexpectedly leave for for episode and
is that tied into the backlash her
character Godwin introduced in season
three are we really gonna believe Tony
is a boxer he's like poor feet tall and
we mostly see him getting the crap
kicked out of him was Diego really that
dumb he was gonna take on a school
shooter with a baseball bat are we gonna
forget that clay lost his virginity to
the sheriff's daughter and it's never
brought up again and it has no impact on
the story whatsoever and most
importantly did clay not clean his pants
after escaping from the hospital thanks
for watching everyone please make sure
to LIKE and subscribe I always have new
videos on the way for more bat takes you
can follow me on twitter at think story
whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much